[music]
>> Greetings all, Dr. Raphael X here with
my returning special guest, Dr. Robert
Spencer. And we're here to talk about
his new book, Holy Hell, which is a just
by the title you can tell is
fascinating. Uh pretty impressive tome
also. Um before anything else, let us
begin with the sign of the cross,
remembering our baptism.
In the name of the Father and of the Son
and of the Holy Spirit. Amen. All right.
Well, uh Dr. Spencer, appreciate you
coming on again talking about your new
book this time.
Always good to talk to you. Thank you.
Yeah, no, thank you. And this book is a
provocative book, but it's very
necessary. Holy Hell, Islam's abuse of
women and the infidels who enabled it.
Uh in this work he Dr. Spencer argues
that certain interpretations of Islamic
tech and legal legal traditions have
contributed to the abuses of women and
non
uh non-Muslims, which we'll we'll
address also.
Uh
I want to ask you Dr. Spencer, did this
book come because you do talk about
doctrine, but you also talk about
current events. Were you inspired kind
of by the revelations of the whole uh
the Muslim the the grooming gangs that
were kind of were discovered there in
England. Was that your uh kind of did
that kind of insight you to write this
book?
Well, I've been covering that activity
actually in Britain for the last 20
years. Mhm.
Uh hadn't thought to write a book about
it, but then it actually what happened
was it came to
notice on an international level Mhm. uh
degree that it never had before. And
that was now I guess about a year ago
when Elon Musk started to call attention
to it. And so I thought now is the time
to put together all the evidence in a
book and show that this is not something
new, but it's been going on for many
years. And while it's happened in
Britain on a scandalous level, it's not
just Britain, either, but it's world a
worldwide phenomenon. And so, it was
uh when Musk started to put pressure on
Keir Starmer's government that I
thought, this needs a book. Right,
right. And you really I mean, it's it's
pretty much doctrinally justified in
Islam. It's just a consequence of their
uh of of their doctrine and also from
Sharia law, which you make the claim, I
believe uh cuz I have this book, which
is really interesting. Uh it's just
Sharia law for non-Muslims. I was just
checking that real quick, just
confirming it cuz you mentioned it also,
where it says the wife beating in the
Quran, right? You which you mentioned
the wife beating and it's kind of
enshrined in Sharia law. Isn't that the
case that that kind of is justified
there?
Wife beating is certainly in the Quran
and allowed in Sharia, but there's more.
Uh
the Quran and Islamic law also allow for
taking infidel women and using them as
sex slaves. This is something people
find absolutely unbelievable, and they
don't think it could possibly be true,
or they think it's just some extreme
interpretation that the vast majority of
Muslims reject. Actually, it's in the
Quran itself, which means no Muslim
actually rejects it, whether they
practice it or not. And it is something
that is practiced all over the world, as
I show in the book, not just in Britain,
uh but in the Islamic world and outside
the Islamic world. Christians in Muslim
countries such as Egypt and Pakistan are
very frequently the targets of this, and
this is one of the reasons why this
behavior is so self-perpetuating
and universal is that it is justified in
core mainstream Islamic teaching.
Right. Uh and shout out to this this
orphanage I help out with this uh in
Pakistan that this Christian lady who's
uh I won't mention her name of course
for safety reasons, but she's definitely
almost underground helping women
who are who live that concretely in in
Pakistan. So definitely even by UN
standards it's not not right by UN
standards. Women just have um less
rights [snorts] than uh in Muslim
countries than non-Muslim countries,
which you alluded to.
Yeah. Well, women are very much second
class in Islam. The Quran says that men
are superior to women, that men can beat
women, that men can have four wives as
well as the captives of the right hand,
which are the sex slaves I was just
discussing, and
you can divorce your wife just by saying
I divorce you.
Now, if you do that once or twice and
you're just getting mad and you you calm
down later, you can take her back. But
if you do it a third time,
then she has to go marry somebody else,
consummate the marriage, and be divorced
by him, and only then can you take her
back. This people think this is crazy
stuff, it's all in the Quran.
Yeah, it's crazy. There's also been
revelations of some prominent Islamic
apologetic apologists what they do the
Dawah Bros who have been uh I think it's
called mut'ah. Is it it has been some
women revealing that they basically had
one night stands, gotten married, and
then gotten divorced. So they kind of
used that, you know, marriage and
divorce to kind of just fulfill their
pretty like fleeting pleasures. It seems
like they did.
>> Yeah.
That's right. Yeah, mut'ah is pleasure
marriage, and it's a marriage with a
deadline.
And so you say, um
I'm going to marry you for a weekend.
And so it's uh often justified in Shiite
Islam. Shiite Islam says that Muhammad
allowed it and they still practice it.
Sunni Islam officially says, "No, no,
no. It was allowed for a temporary
period, but then Muhammad stopped it and
forbade it." However, there are a lot of
people among Sunni Muslims who actually
disagree with that idea and they tend
more toward the Shiite view that it's
still allowed. And so, the Dawah guys
that you're talking about, they're
Sunnis
in Britain like Muhammad Hijab, and they
uh but they subscribe to what is
generally considered to be more of a
Shiite understanding. And it's really
just prostitution essentially. Um as a
matter of fact, the you find it most
commonly when you're talking about
Shiite Islam in seminary towns.
It's very interesting because, you know,
you would ordinarily think of a seminary
as a place where there the people there
are very serious about the religion, and
so they're not going to be engaging in
sinful behavior. I mean, of course,
everyone's a sinner, but not engaging in
such a free and open manner
in sinful behavior. But in Islam, at
least in Shiite Islam, there's there's
no problem with this. It's not sinful.
And so, you have a lot of young men in
seminary towns who are away from home
for the first time.
And they there are large numbers of what
are essentially prostitutes in these
towns like Qom and other places. Qom is
the famous Shiite holy city, and they uh
uh congregate there because they know
there'll be a lot of young men there who
will marry them for a weekend and give
them a so-called dowry. It's essentially
just paying for a prostitute. And then
after the weekend, the deadline is over
and it's all over. The trouble Muhammad
Hijab got in as far as I understand it
is that he was promising to marry some
young woman or women. I'm not entirely
familiar with the case, but he uh
didn't inform them that it he intended
that that to be a temporary marriage,
that he was essentially just going to be
using them for sexual pleasure and then
throwing them away. So, they thought
they were entering into a genuine
relationship and he was behaving as if
they were prostitutes. That's
tremendous, tremendous. This is the real
evil
>> Yeah, the real evil for them, I guess,
is when it's exposed, when it's
exteriorized, because it's that the
whole doctrine of taqiyya, which we
talked about your the last interview we
had, which is the kind of that
justification of dis- dissimulating,
right? The living a double life, which
is very
>> Yeah, it's also humiliating.
Sorry, I didn't mean to cut you off, but
humiliation is very important in Islam.
It's very important because the Quran in
chapter 9, verse 29, uh which is the
primary verse calling for warfare
against Christians, it says, "Fight
against the people of the book," which
is primarily Jews as well as Christians,
uh
until they pay the jizya, the tax, with
willing submission and feel themselves
subdued. So, see, it's a duty before
Allah that the Muslims have to make the
unbelievers humiliated.
To make them understand that they're on
a lower plane than the Muslims. And so,
Islamic apologists like Muhammad Hijab
and Islamic jihadis who are actually
violent, they traffic in intimidation to
a tremendous degree.
This is why we see actually a lot of
fake bomb threats from uh Muslims.
They're not just uh you know, we think,
"Oh, it was a fake threat. The guy's
some kind of nut." No, he was just
trying to strike terror in the enemies
of Allah and humiliate them without
actually going to the extent of killing
them all for whatever reason. He might
not have had the materials to build a
real bomb or something of that kind. So,
when it comes to
getting this exposed,
Mohammed Hijab becomes the one
humiliated, and this is wrong. This is
against the natural order of things. He
should be humiliating the Kufar, the
unbelievers. But, when he gets
humiliated in front of them,
then this is even worse because the
Muslims are on a higher plane than the
non-Muslims. And so, for a Muslim to be
humiliated is a tremendous shame, a
tremendous dishonor. And that is the
real problem for him and why this is
such a scandal. He doesn't really care
about the women. He doesn't really care
that it's exposed that he's buying
temporary marriages.
That's all sanctioned
as far as he's concerned. But, the
humiliation, the big problem.
Yeah, that that points to the
anthropology of Islam cuz correctly if
correct me if I'm wrong, I mean the
Christian view is basically we have a
natural dignity rooted in that in the
fact that we're created in the image and
likeness of God. But, for Islam, it's as
if there is no there isn't this
fundamental dignity. Just a Muslim has
more dignity, and you really don't have
dignity if you're not if you're not
Islamic and and much less if you're a
woman a woman.
Exactly so. And this is very important.
The Quran in chapter 48 verse 29 says
Muhammad is the apostle of Allah. Those
who follow him are ruthless to
unbelievers, merciful to one another.
Now, that it seems to me is more or less
a direct contradiction to the Christian
idea that all human beings are made in
the image of God and equal in dignity.
Instead, you have the Muslims to whom
you're merciful and the non-Muslims to
whom you are ruthless. they are not on
the same plane. They are not the same as
the meme goes. They the non-Muslims have
to be humiliated and the non-Muslim and
the Muslims exalted. And this is the
natural order of things. Not any idea,
there's no idea in Islam of the equal
dignity of all people before God or of
human beings being created in the image
of God. That appears kind of obliquely
in the Hadith, but it's not a major
Islamic doctrine and does not appear in
the Quran. And the idea of the that I'm
sketching out here of the of the Muslims
being on a higher level is much
reinforced much more strongly than any
such idea in Islam.
I just want to say cuz some people might
think you don't need any introduct-
introduction Dr. Spencer, but you've
been studying this for decades. You
you've written
over 50 books. So really you're in the
know. So you're you're the go-to and
even Congress you had a hearing. I want
to mention this. You had a hearing on
kind of this the growing Islamization. I
don't know if that was the general
topic. You maybe you could tell the
specific topic. The growing Islamization
in America and kind of the the more the
the prevalence of of Sharia law
especially in certain states like in
Texas and things like that. So that's
that's really interesting.
I don't know if you want to
say anything about Sure.
Yeah, in the first place only 32 books
I've written, but
the whole set they're available on
Amazon. And
the
hearing was before a house subcommittee
about Sharia about the Constitution and
limited government is the house
subcommittee and the hearing was about
Sharia. And it was a very interesting
experience.
The Democrats on the committee
Congressman Raskin of Maryland I think
he's from and Steve Cohen of Tennessee
as well as Mary Gay Scanlon of
Pennsylvania. they all persistently
characterized Sharia as if it were
personal private religious law for
matters of
arbitration and marriage, things like
that. Totally voluntary. And they
characterized any kind of opposition to
it as simple religious bigotry and
Islamophobia.
And they persistently ignored or denied
outright any idea that Islam actually
teaches warfare against unbelievers, has
a political extension, that Sharia has a
political extension as well as a
religious one, and that it's not a
matter of bigotry or hatred to oppose a
a political ideological system that is
violent, supremacist, aggressive, and
expansionist, and that it denies basic
rights to those who don't hold to it.
That's right. That's right. And what's
interesting is a lot of uh turning to
your book, a lot of what the left hates
in Christianity exists exponentially
um in in Islam. For example, like
modesty. Let's do women, for example,
which you you allude to. Women are are
totally covered up. And maybe you can
give the origins in that, because I'm
not sure if that had to do with
Muhammad's kind of insecurity with his
concubines or wives, but women in some
places you have even their eyes covered
up, where there's a total covering. So,
why is this there this this kind of uh
you know, this extreme view and this
this modesty, if you will, this
disordered modesty in women?
Yeah, you know, it's interesting because
uh
there is a meme going around. I see it
every now and again. I I would expect
that you've seen it, but if you haven't,
you will eventually. And it's got a two
photos side by side. One is of a Roman
Catholic nun, and the other is of a
woman in hijab. And it says, "If you've
got a problem with one of these, but not
the other,
then you're a racist bigot Islamophobe.
And
the the it's a trick that that meme.
It's it's uh
uh a slight of hand, so to speak,
because really there's no comparison
between the two. A nun takes order
religious orders voluntarily.
Uh I mean, enters into a uh convent and
takes religious vows, I mean to say,
voluntarily.
Right. And nobody is forcing her to do
it. And nobody is saying all women have
to dress this way in in Christianity.
You know, certainly Christianity teaches
modesty, but modesty is going to change
in its specific
uh expression from culture to culture
and time to time.
Whereas in Islam, I can give you
numerous examples of women who've been
brutalized or even killed for not
wearing hijab.
Uh it is something that's forced on the
basis of terror and fear that if you
don't wear it, you could get beaten, you
could get killed, you could get
ostracized from the community. And so
there's just no comparison between the
two.
Uh the basis of the hijab in Islam is in
the Quran that uh says chapter 24:31
women should draw their draw their veils
over their over their bosoms. Chapter
33:59 says this as well. Says that they
do it so that they are not molested.
And so [clears throat] the unspoken
corollary of that or the flip side is
that
well, if you don't
veil, then you can lawfully be molested.
And this is actually how Muslims in
Europe and increasingly in North America
have been treating non-Muslim women,
because they figure, well, they're not
veiled.
And so they're signaling that they
actually want this and so they attack
them. Now, this comes all this comes
from various Hadiths in which Muhammad
first mandates that his wives be veiled
and then mandates it for all Muslim
women.
And the idea is that it's the
responsibility of the women to make sure
that the men are not tempted.
In Christianity, we have the idea
of custody of the eyes that you you
you're tempted by seeing women, well,
look look at something else. Look away.
It's up to you to exercise self-control
and to develop the virtue of chastity on
the basis of that self-control. But,
there's no such idea in Islam. Doesn't
exist. If the women have to cover
themselves and if they don't, the men
are perfectly justified in it in raping
them.
Right.
>> And so, this is another justification
for the rape gangs that we've seen in
Britain and elsewhere that the women are
not covered. Because the if they if they
want to ward off being attacked, then
they have to cover up.
And to their everlasting shame, actually
some Western leaders now have started to
say that.
That well, our women are going to have
to start dressing like the Muslim women
so as not to inflame the the young
Muslim men with temptation.
Nobody's telling the young Muslim men to
control themselves, at least of all
Islam itself.
Yeah, why do you think there is this
capitulation to that? And why are
there's it seems like there's this trend
like with Lily Jay, I'm sure you've
heard of her. These shorts I've seen
these shorts always come on my feed of
Muslimas, I think that's how you call
Muslim women, and even they're they're
doing Dawah with with hijabs. Like
they're letting foreigners, foreigners
for them, which are European natives,
put on hijabs and it's all positive.
They all they're all loving it and
things like that. But there seems to be,
and I don't know because it's this
effeminate we're living in a feminist
secularist and and and sadly,
you know, post-Christian era where where
it seems like the the feminists are
finding attractiveness in this strong
masculinism,
in this, you know, disordered
patriarchy, if you will, in Islam. It's
What's What's happening here?
Well, I think you actually hit on
something very important there.
That
feminists are rejecting Christianity,
rejecting the idea that they call
patriarchy
of males being in charge or males having
a certain kind of headship in the
family.
But then they go and embrace a
caricature of it that is even more
virulently anti-female
and even more assertive and aggressive
about males being the head of the
family. Now, why on earth would they do
that? Well, it's complicated question,
of course, but I do think that at least
in some cases it emanates from
exactly that disorder, that they're
longing for what they've rejected
because it is the natural order of
things. And this is not to say men are
superior to women or should beat women
or anything of the kind. You know, you
study the famous chapter of St. Paul's
letter to the Ephesians, which is read
during the marriage ceremony, or at
least it's read during the Orthodox
marriage ceremony.
The
The How does it go? I don't have this
Bible right with me, but you know, the
famous passage, "Husbands, love your
wives as Christ loved the church and
gave himself up for her.
Wives, be submissive to your husbands."
And that drives feminists crazy. "Wives,
be submissive to your husbands." And
they never consider the fact that the
the same passage says husbands love your
love your wives as Christ loved the
church, which is a tremendous
self-emptying.
And the great divine humility in taking
on man and
the sacrificing himself to open heaven
for us. This is
a mutuality that is completely absent
from Islam.
And so, that is the the the natural
order of things where you do have a
hierarchy, but it's not a hierarchy of
domination or of exploitation
or of terror or anything of the kind.
But, in the absence of it, in the
explicit rejection of it, there is a
certain longing in the soul for it
because that's how we were created. And
so, they see this caricature of it.
Excuse me, especially at the time
when so many Christians, including
leaders of the church, are are so
embarrassed by this and abandoning it
and not teaching it.
And then they see in Islam, they got no
problem. They never retreat if even 1
in. They always teach what they're all
about. And they so they think, "Well,
that that's what I want." And so, they
don't even realize that they're
contradicting themselves. They're just
answering a deeper longing within their
own soul.
Right. Right. Yeah, I know that that's
that's really interesting. Um yeah. And
it seems like there is an attractiveness
to that.
But, what about like I I could kind of
sympathize because I think a lot of
Muslims they conflate secularism with
Christianity and it's almost blurred
sadly. It's almost blurred in many
instances where
uh there's just a wholehearted embrace
with
with mainstream or mainline in many
ways. at least in the Catholic Church,
the hierarchy, I mean it's a total
embrace of of the modern world. And
Muslims, they conflate both both of
those.
And so I can understand, in a sense, a
Muslim who's in a secular society seeing
women, you know, the feminism, for
example, and wanting to go back to
um wanting to go back to more
traditional values. I think there are
Muslims that are kind of um
well-intentioned in a sense and and see
and if you agree with this trend, let me
know, but I find back in the home
countries of many of these Muslim
countries, they're becoming more
uh
more moderate as opposed to the European
countries where immigrants are going,
there's more hardline Muslims. Is Is
that Is that the case or I'm not sure.
It seems to me that's that's what's
what's happening, at least, I don't
know.
Well, yeah, there are a lot of things
happening and it's a very large area,
but one of the general things that we
can pinpoint is in a lot of places where
Islamic law has been very strictly
enforced for a long time, people are
thoroughly sick of it. Mhm.
>> And it's being relaxed.
Uh most notably,
Saudi Arabia,
where they've been very hardline for a
long time, but now uh
over the last few years, the Saudi
government has actually started to lift
some of the Islamic restrictions on
things or
reinterpret them, so they allow women to
drive now and things like that. And the
idea is to make Saudi Arabia more
attractive for foreign investment
because they realize that
the oil-based economy may be on its way
out, that uh
certainly the whole establishment left
wants to abandon it and go to electric
and solar and so on. And so,
uh uh they don't want to end up being
impoverished as they were before they
struck oil. They want to diversify their
economy, and so they're
uh getting rid of some of the least
appealing aspects of it. But that also
coincides so the people in many cases
are very happy that for that to happen
because, well, you know, a lot of
Muslims don't want to live under Islamic
law anymore than anybody else because it
is so draconian. And so they're happy to
leave it. In Iran, of course, it's still
very strictly enforced, and that's one
of the reasons why the people hate the
regime. And they're not only just hating
the regime, but the regime being so
closely identified with Islam itself
is leading people to leave Islam in
large numbers. And a survey a few years
back was shocking, showed that less than
40% of the people in Iran now identify
as a Muslim. Oh, wow.
>> That's so It's officially 99% Islamic,
but so it's been so unpleasant for the
people to live under Muslim rule all
these years that most of the population
is now abandoned Islam.
Now, then on the other hand, you have
the migrants to Europe.
>> Mhm. The migrants to Europe are a
variety of people, of course, but one of
the groups you have are people who are
going there because they're poor in
their home countries, and they
understand that Europe is rich, and they
want to live comfortable lives. So
they're what's known as economic
migrants. But they're also migrants, and
this is very little noted, but it's uh
quite clear from numerous sort of
man-on-the-street interviews, statements
of the migrants themselves, they are
emigrating for the sake of Allah, which
is a concept we find in the Quran.
Chapter 4:100 states that those who
emigrate for the sake of Allah
can be sure of a great reward from
Allah.
So,
what does it mean to emigrate for the
sake of Allah? You're emigrating like
Muhammad did when he moved from Mecca to
Medina, and he became for the first time
a political and spirit military leader
as well as a spiritual one.
So, he takes on political and military
power for the first time. If you
emigrate for the sake of Allah to a
non-Muslim society, you're committing
yourself to working to bring Islam
there.
And ultimately to gain political power
there. This is why we see such small
groups of Muslims in the West often
wielding political power
with to a proportion beyond their
numbers.
Like we have a very small percentage of
Muslims in the United States, and yet
they got three congressmen,
not only Ilhan Omar and Rashida Tlaib,
but Andre Carson, who's much lower
profile, and they are running for office
at all levels of the US government uh
in order to gain political power and
increase their influence beyond all
proportion to the actual Muslim
population in the country. And this is
because Islam is political, but this is
all part of what it means to emigrate
for the sake of Allah. So, in many
Muslim countries, in some, you have a
lot of people who are sick of Islam,
and they are going to not observe it as
much as they can get away with. Whereas
a lot of the people coming to the West
are actually very serious about Islam
and are trying to bring it here. Right.
Right. Interesting. I did see a poll
about it. I think it was 85%
in the UK, I believe, or or more. They
wanted to the establishment of Sharia
law kind of more generalized in the UK.
So, I I was shocked about that, but
yeah, that's that's really interesting.
So, but coming to a new country, and
they they basically want to make it a
dump like from where they came from.
Unfortunately, that's that's that's
really interesting. Um but regard So,
the the political kind of the political
takeover, if you will, is that kind of
like cuz I've heard the concept of a
silent or a
a pacific, if you will, jihad. Kind of
Is that like a political jihad? I mean,
their end goal is to kind of
to take over. Is it Is it Is that right?
When you kind of mentioned that.
Yeah, there's no doubt about it. And at
jihadwatch.org,
which is my own website, I track jihad
activity in the United States and around
the world every day. And I've seen a
sharp increase over the last couple of
years in Muslims openly saying in Europe
and in America that they're here to take
over.
And this is because, as I've explained,
Islam has this supremacist imperative.
They consider it to be part of their
religion.
And
the left in America and in Britain and
all over continental Europe is in total
denial about this and refuses to look at
the evidence that this is exactly what
the objective is.
But if they really want to
continue to ignore it, then you're we're
going to look in Britain at what life
will be like for the non-Muslims in 50
years or 100 years. It's going to be
like the Coptic Christians in Egypt. Or
the Christians in Pakistan, a small
minority denied basic rights by a
massive Muslim majority and the small
minority in Egypt, remember, those
Christians are the indigenous people of
the land just like the people in
Britain.
Right, right. No, that that makes sense.
And um
would you say like
w-
How would you respond to people who say
like oh you know Dubai, Qatar, these are
Muslim nations that are not really
follow that trend. Are they Are they
successful? It seems like they are
successful despite of Islam not with
Islam. Like kind of uh
the because of the rejection of Islam.
Like why are there Muslim countries?
Like these are countries that are I mean
their airports are amazing. You know, I
I travel. Uh I've been to Pakistan. I've
been I've been to the Middle East and
you go to the airports like Qatar
and it's like it is impressive and it
does seem like even though it could be
at surface level, it does seem like
there's there's harmony there. Um I've
met Catholics there. So it's um yeah,
what what do you say to that when people
bring those countries up?
Well, first thing, the Catholics that
you met in Qatar, were they Qatari or
were they foreign?
>> Yeah. The The Qataris recently I know
Tucker Carlson was talking about the
Christians in Qatar and comparing them
favorably to the situation of Christians
in Israel. But he didn't mention the
fact that there aren't any Qatari
Christians. They are foreign workers
>> Mhm. who go there for economic reasons
and the Qataris accommodate them to a
certain degree, but to a very restricted
degree. For one thing, the the the
there's a Catholic church there if I if
my memory serves me right and it doesn't
have any sign outside that it's a
church. No cross, nothing because Islam
does not allow outward display of the
non-Muslims religions.
And especially on the Arabian Peninsula,
it is forbidden because Muhammad said,
"I will ban ban the Jews and Christians
from Arabia." And the people on the
Arabian Peninsula have taken that very
seriously. This is why no non-Muslim
religious expression is allowed in Saudi
Arabia, even now while they're
modernizing.
So, Qatar, yeah, they want to make money
and they do it very well.
But, at the same time, they are spending
a lot of that money
in the United States, in funding
American universities. Now, what do they
What are they buying when they fund
American universities? They're not just
giving the money out of the kindness of
their heart and saying, "Use it how you
see best." They want Middle Eastern
studies programs that teach a rosy,
whitewashed version of Islam. And that's
what you get in colleges and
universities all around the country.
They want the people to hate Israel and
to support the Palestinian jihad.
When October 7th, the jihad massacre had
happened in Israel and 1,200 Israelis
were murdered, the American universities
immediately started to protest and
agitate in favor of Hamas. Why? Because
this is what they'd been taught, that
Israel is a terrible oppressor and that
Hamas is in the right. And they were
taught that by professors who are funded
from Qatar.
Mhm. So, this is what they are doing
with the money. Also, there's the Muslim
Brotherhood. The Muslim Brotherhood is
an international organization
that is dedicated to imposing Sharia
Islamic law around the world
and ultimately to restoring the
caliphate. It was actually founded in
Egypt in 1928 by people who were angry
because the last caliph had been deposed
in 1924 in secular Turkey.
And they wanted to restore the
caliphate. The caliph is the successor
of Muhammad as the political, military,
and spiritual leader of the Muslims. And
the idea of the caliphate,
although this is theory, this was never
fully realized in practice, but it's
still a very powerful theory. The idea
was that the caliphate is the whole sole
legitimate government to which Muslims
worldwide owe allegiance, and it
transcends all other allegiances on
Earth. So, you don't say I'm a
Pakistani, or I'm an Iranian, or I'm an
Afghan, or I'm an Egyptian, you say I'm
a member of the caliphate of the ummah.
Now, the Ottoman Empire was the last
caliphate, and it's gone. And it's been
100 years now since there's been a
caliph.
So,
the jihadist terror groups around the
world have it as one of their primary
goals that what they want to do is
destroy the existing governments of the
world so that an Islamic caliphate can
replace them.
And so, the unity of the Muslims can be
restored.
And then they will be able to wage
offensive jihad, which is the province
of the caliph alone. Right now, we're
only seeing defensive jihad. So,
the the idea is to restore the caliphate
so that they have this unified Muslim
government. Now,
that's the Muslim Brotherhood. That's
the whole idea of the Muslim
Brotherhood, to destroy existing
governments and replace them with
Sharia, and ultimately to
uh
merge all the Sharia states into one
caliphate.
The Muslim Brotherhood is active in the
United States. All the major Muslim
organizations in the United States are
linked in one way or another to the
Muslim Brotherhood.
And the Muslim Brotherhood, according to
a captured internal document, states,
"The brothers must understand that their
goal in America is a kind of grand jihad
in eliminating and destroying Western
civilization from within, and sabotaging
its miserable house by their hands, that
is the hands of the people in Western
civilization, and the hands of the
believers, so that it falls and Allah's
religion is victorious over other
religions. That's the Muslim Brotherhood
program for the United States.
And all the major Muslim groups are on
board.
And they're all the Muslim Brotherhood.
So, that where they getting the money
for all this?
From Qatar.
So, that's Qatar.
Now, it's true, it's not a strict
Islamic state like Iran, because it
wants to attract foreign money
in order to give it to the Muslim
Brotherhood for precisely this purpose.
The UAE and Dubai, Dubai is part of the
United Arab Emirates, it's a little
different. They really are just in it
for the money. And you we have to
understand that just because somebody
bears the name of Muslim doesn't mean
that they're always going to be acting
to further Islam or in accord with
Islam. Just as Christians don't always
act in the accord with the teachings of
Christianity. And so,
>> [clears throat]
>> the UAE is a state that is
chasing some pragmatic imperatives right
now, that they want to make money as
well. Uh
there is a downside though, it's not
like they're completely secular.
Uh Abu Dhabi and Dubai, you know, that
become um
Uh I mean, Dubai the the
has become kind of a resort area, and
people go there on vacation. But, there
have been
women Western women there who've been
arrested for being raped.
Because see here again, what we were
discussing before, it's the woman's
fault if a man is tempted. It's the
woman's responsibility, so she has to
cover up so that he's not tempted. And
if she gets raped, she has failed to
stop him from being tempted, so she goes
to prison.
75% of the women in Pakistan are in
prison because they were raped.
And that's that's a statistic that comes
from a Muslim women's organization that
is working to change all that. But
that's what happens all too often to
women in Dubai. So yeah, they have a an
inviting secular facade and certainly
they do not enforce Islamic law to its
fullest degree, but they do enforce it
uh to a degree much more than most
Westerners realize. Yeah. Yeah, maybe
maybe in a future video. I don't know if
you have a book on
eschatology, but really the the what's
happening now and
talking about it in another video, but
um kind of the unification of Islam
under the caliphate, the Mahdi. It seems
like those times are near at least. Uh
there's a very interesting book called
The Islamic Antichrist. I don't know if
you're familiar with it. It's actually
>> Yeah, that's Joel Richardson, right?
>> Joel Richardson, yeah, which is not I
don't know.
>> but Joel's a good guy. Yeah. Yeah, I is
that his real name? I what I understand
is his pen name. It's not his not his
actual name. But I don't know I can't
comment on that, but Joel Richardson is
a guy you can find by that name. Oh,
okay.
>> [laughter]
>> Okay, maybe I misread. Maybe I misread.
I thought that he
he talked about dangers was, but very
fascinating book. But yeah, we can get
into that some other time because that
is the parallels there are really
amazing. And I was just kind of reminded
of that when you were talking about kind
of everything happening. But yeah,
turning turning to women Let me just say
one Yeah, please. I I'm sorry to
interrupt again, but
when you're talking about Islamic
eschatology, there is one thing that I
often like to mention that I think your
listeners, your your viewers will find
very interesting and that isn't often
remarked upon. There is a Hadith that is
a tradition of Muhammad's words and
deeds. That's what the Hadith are.
There's a Hadith in which Muhammad says
that there is nobody more hateful in the
sight of Allah
on the day of judgment
than the one who calls himself the king
of kings.
Wow.
So, you see the the Islamic idea of the
end times where Jesus is a Muslim
prophet who comes back and destroys
Christianity. He breaks the cross and so
on. This is completely opposed to
Christian eschatology. And it is the the
the bad guys are the good guys and vice
versa. Yeah. And so
the [clears throat] the end times as
Islam envisions it, the worst person is
going to be the king of king.
That's right. That's going to be their
false prophet, which is the and their
Isa is going to be our false prophet.
Their Isa is going to be the when he
comes back saying, "No, no, you guys got
it all wrong. I wasn't this I wasn't God
actually. I was just I was just a man."
And that's going to be the
>> That's the definition of Antichrist.
>> That's the definition of Antichrist. So,
the Mahdi So, Joel Richardson makes that
the argument that the Mahdi would
actually be the Antichrist. And the
prophet that we proclaim um another
prophet, the the speaker for the
Antichrist. I think it's a
I forget the name the the the precursor
of the Antichrist will actually be their
their Isa or vice versa. I forget. But
yeah, it's very The parallels are really
amazing. And it's very interesting. And
it's it's almost as as if Satan uh
through the religious deception, which
is we In the Catechism of the Catholic
Church it says that the Antichrist will
come and deceive people through some
type of religious deception. So, that
deception seems like you know uh
Islam at least cuz it it's under the
veil of righteousness. It's almost like
you see on the outside these people are
very righteous.
Yes.
>> It's deceiving in that sense. It's not
explicitly evil. You're seeing people in
robes. I mean, you're seeing people
modestly dressed. You're seeing people
pray. Right? Praying in postures that
are very you know that adoring postures.
So, it's
it's very interesting in that sense.
But also what about this
turning to women?
How do you explain that that Muhammad's
his parents Correct me if I'm wrong. His
parents are in hell, right? And both his
mother and his father, or at least he
implies that they're in hell, cuz he
didn't want to pray for them. But but
the Virgin Mary, uh she is the most
exalted woman in the Quran. So, how how
do we explain How is that make sense?
His parents are in hell because they're
not believers in the one God. But it's
There's so much ambiguity and
contradiction in the Hadith, because
it's all later traditions. And so, there
are also traditions that say where
Muhammad says that every believer who
goes to paradise will be able to take
people with him, certain number of
people with them, including his parents.
So, they may not be.
But there are numerous passages of the
Quran that says even if your father or
your brother rejects this, then you have
to reject them.
That uh For example, there's a very
famous passage in chapter 60 of the
Quran, verse 4, where uh it says Abraham
is an excellent example for the
believers. Now, that's very big. The
excellent example means a model for
emulation, because Muhammad is called
that in chapter 33, verse 21 of the
Quran. And Muhammad is the model of
emulation for every activity for a
believing Muslim. If Muhammad did it,
it's good and should be imitated. And
so, to to say that about Abraham is very
big. But then they There's a big
exception, which there are no exceptions
for Muhammad. Chapter 60, verse 4 goes
on to say that Abraham is an excellent
example when he says to his father,
"There will be enmity and hatred between
us and you forever, because you do not
worship the one God."
And so, that's what you got to emulate
Abraham in, hating your father if he's
not a Muslim.
Mhm. Wow.
>> You don't emulate him and then goes on
to say, but he's not a model of
emulation when he says, but I'll pray
for you.
So, it's even worse. You don't imitate
him when he says to pray for your
unbelieving father.
Wow. Yeah, that's uh
that that's really shocking. That's
really shocking.
Um
and Dr. Spencer just kind of uh
wrapping it up a little bit. Some
someone has asked me and I was thinking
this is perfect for this interview. So,
the men cuz I mean it it seems like
what's exalted is is lust. Lust is
exalted. Someone told me Islam is a sexy
religion.
And I think that's how why the first
followers find it attractive in many
way, the concubines, the booty you get.
But really why? So, when men die, they
get the the houris, right? The women.
And do women believe that they will be
one of the houris when they die? What do
they get?
That's ambiguous. Islam does not
actually say anything. The Quran doesn't
say anything. The Hadith doesn't say
anything about what paradise will be
like for the women.
And so,
uh
there was recently
a Muslim woman wearing hijab who made a
video.
And she said that
uh
you
a lot of Muslim women are not really
happy about the prospect of paradise
because they think they're going to be
watching their husbands having sex with
these houris for all eternity. And so,
what is paradisal about that? And this
woman explains that they're actually
going to get a lot of stuff.
They're going to get jewels and and and
fine clothes and all these things. It's
a very It's a physical place, uh
Muslim paradise. And
uh she acts as if this is good. And it
just reminded me
of Charles de Foucauld,
uh who I believe is a Roman Catholic
saint if I'm not mistaken. 19th century
Catholic missionary to North Africa.
Now, in his younger years, he had been
a libertine.
And then he had a religious conversion
and became a monk, and he went to North
Africa to live among the Muslims and to
try to bring them to Christ. And he
explained that he knew
that Islam was not true when he saw what
it taught as paradise because he had
tasted the pleasures of the flesh and he
knew they were not the highest good.
And he knew that they did not satisfy
the longings of the human soul.
And so he knew that Islam's degraded
sensuality showed that it was a false
religion.
Right.
>> And I think there's a great deal of
wisdom in that to that has never
actually been confronted by any
Muslim spokesman because they can't
really say these are spiritualized
these are descriptions of something in
human terms that will be actually far
beyond that because literalism is
mainstream in Islam. A lot of people
would call them a heretic if they said
something like that.
Yeah, no, that makes sense.
And if just a last to just to answer
criticisms cuz there are people I I have
I know people who are fans of yours. I
know people who are critics of yours as
I'm sure you do, of course, of yourself.
So, I'm sure you get a lot of flak for
what you do, which is kudos to you for
your courage. Um how do you
reply to people who are I'm sure the the
main criticism is oh, you're just
generalizing. You're unfairly
generalizing about Islam. That's what
your work does. What What do you say? I
don't I'm guessing that's the principal
criticism.
Yeah, I've heard that, but uh
uh I think it's kind of ridiculous
because
um
I am merely actually most of my work is
just reporting on what the Quran says
and then how it's understood by
mainstream Islamic scholars and how it's
applied in the world by actual Muslims.
And so they can't really deny that. They
say, "Well, you were uh yeah, you're
ignoring all the wonderful peaceful
tolerant aspects."
Uh
and I say, "Okay, where are they?
Show me.
Um what am I exactly missing?
Um where is there country in the world
today where non-Muslims enjoy full
equality of rights with Muslims? There
isn't one.
Uh at very least there are restrictions
on proselytizing for the Christians but
not for the Muslims like in Turkey.
And so
uh
that's that's one problem and the other
is where is this form of Islam? I look
around in the world and I see there are
many Muslims who don't follow all these
teachings of the Quran that we've been
discussing
and all the other nosh- noxious aspects
of it.
But I do not see an actual form of Islam
that teaches an understanding of Islam
that allows for equality between men and
women, that allows for the full dignity
and rights of non-Muslims or the freedom
of speech.
Instead, I see all the sects and all the
schools of jurisprudence teach the death
penalty for blasphemy, teach the
inequality of men with women, and the
inequality of Muslims with non-Muslims.
So I say, "Show me a form of Islam that
actually teaches tolerance and equality
and peace."
Well, I've never seen one. So you're
telling me the religion is not a
religion of peace. So that's
Yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> And people like to Sometimes they say,
"Oh, well, what about the Ismaili Shia
or the Ahmadiyya?" And these are And we
can get into the specifics of those
examples.
Uh I would dispute both of them, but
even if we granted that they are
peaceful, tolerant versions of Islam,
they represent a very small minority of
Muslims worldwide.
Uh, 1%, 2%, and so, you know, what if I
said that some Protestant group that was
1% of Christians worldwide is the real
thing? And we should just discount all
the rest. You would say, "Well, that's
stupid. You should look at the major
uh forms of it and the and the that most
people hold and the ones that have most
people have held traditionally
throughout history." And that will give
you a much more representative idea.
Well, that's what I'm doing. That's
right. I guess the Muslims expect you to
be like them with a taqiyya, you know,
you're supposed to dissimulate the
reality.
And you know, portray it for what it's
not. So, very good. Well, holy hell, if
I could just ask you the last question,
um I I love the title. I thought that
because I heard this that everyone goes
to hell.
Uh even Muslims go to hell. Is that Is
that the case? But then they're they're
extracting from hell.
Yeah, there's a hadith to that effect.
But this book is actually not about hell
as such or about the uh what happens
after death for Muslims. It's about
Islam's mistreatment of women and how
it's justified by Islamic texts and
teachings. And that this mistreatment of
women, the sex slavery, the other things
we discussed before, they're all in the
Quran, they're all allowed by Islam, and
this is why this is going on in Britain
and elsewhere, and why we're going to
see more of it because everybody's still
in total denial about it.
Well, guys, get this book. This book is
excellent. It's also also
Islam's abuse of women and the infidels
who enable it, which is really, you
know, we we cannot allow. We have to
speak up, basically, which what you're
doing. And that And that's really
excellent. So, guys, get this book. It's
very, like all of Dr. Spencer's um
readings, is very accessible. I mean,
you write
uh you write profoundly, but in a way
that is not uh it's not difficult to
read. So, that that's really that's
really awesome and that's a gift
actually.
Um, well, thanks for coming on. We
appreciate you. Hope hopefully we'll
like to have you on your
for your next book, which will probably
be next month.
Uh,
as a matter of fact, you're right. It is
coming next
The the tragedy of Islam, failure and
excuses and that's
>> Oh, wow. So, wow.
>> all about how Islam doesn't work. Uh, it
doesn't make your life better and it
doesn't make societies better. And I
approve both in that book. Awesome.
Awesome. So, yes, uh hope hopefully to
have you I hope to have you on again.
And uh well, thanks for coming on. And
God bless you all for listening. And uh
thank you very much.
All right.